a couple years ago Rand Paul ran for
president and the media ass has the
libertarian moment finally arrived but
Paul's presidential campaign went
nowhere
all Rand Paul shouldn't even be on this
stage he's number 11 he's got 1% in the
polls I had high hopes this was going to
be the libertarian moment the crowd was
cheering we've come to take our country
back what happened I would say that
either the people aren't ready or
perhaps the people in the Republican
primary aren't ready since Trump was
elected federal spending has risen about
half a trillion dollars it doesn't mean
some of us aren't fighting it just means
we're losing the battle but I think
there are a lot of battles you lose in
Washington that you may be winning the
hearts and minds of people who aren't in
Washington are we winning hearts and
minds that's what I try to do with these
videos but I wouldn't say that we're
winning with socialism newly popular
Senator Paul felt compelled to write
this book making the case against it
more on that in another video but Paul
says progress has been made and evidence
of it is President Trump
implementing Senator Paul's free market
ideas on health care
let competition drive prices down
president said it's a great idea Paul
then tweeted that he's proud to stand
with President Trump that together we
cut taxes repealed regulations and put
better judges on the court the plan is
to get out of endless wars Paul also
praised the president for saying he'd
bring our soldiers home the very bold
move for president Trump it's exactly
what he promised the American people
Paul tweeted the first president to
understand what our national interest is
but he hasn't pulled out of anywhere
compared to george w bush who got us
involved everywhere or compared to
president obama who sent a hundred
thousand troops to afghanistan the
rhetoric of President Trump has actually
been I think a relief bring our soldiers
back home to not be policing agents all
over the world has it happened yet
no but I continue to push we should get
out of Afghanistan but when the
president has said anything about it
when I have supported him
immediately the Republican leaders and
the Democrat leaders get together and
they hurry and they immediately pass a
resolution saying it would be
precipitous to leave Afghanistan the
danger of a precipitous withdrawal
really after 19 years precipitous
America went into Afghanistan to take
out the killers behind the September
11th attack we did that but we're still
there 18 years later you look at
intervention after intervention after
intervention we haven't had the intended
consequence we've gotten more chaos
erupted at an American outpost in
Afghanistan in Iraq we took out Saddam
Saddam Hussein captured a lie but the
people who replaced him were often worse
we got rid of Gaddafi the dictator but
what replaced him isn't better in Syria
we armed rebels to fight Assad but often
our weapons ended up in the hands of al
Qaeda everything we think we're gonna
get more of stability or less terrorism
we ended up getting more chaos and more
terrorism so President Trump has rights
as Paul when he says we want to bring
our soldiers back home recently Trump
moved some troops from northern Syria he
moved 50 out of the way and all the
Warhawk caucus have gone crazy
leaving the Kurds for slaughter this
reckless action this is the most screwed
up decision I've seen since I've been in
Congress he had that awesome dasa t2
move 50 soldiers and it's like these
people are insane
a betrayal of the strongest allies four
years ago you said the United States
should arm the Kurds promised them their
own country and now those 50 soldiers
were presumably keeping the Turks from
killing the Kurds you've abandoned them
when I refer to the Kurds having a
homeland they kind of do they have a
section of Iraq I know they would wish
they would hope it to be a country but I
never really have advocated that we
would mandate or protect some sort of
new country within Syria for the Kurds
the bottom line is the people who live
there know better about this a very
complicated war of their four or five
different you know countries involved in
it we can't know enough about these
problems and unless you want to put a
hundred thousand troops in there and
fight Assad rush Turkey we ought to
rethink whether we should get involved
in these wars to begin with
I promise you 50 soldiers work 2,000
American soldiers are nothing more than
a target for bad people to kill or to
maim which will get us drugged into a
bigger war I don't know whether Senator
Paul is right about Syria but 18 years
of war in the Middle East America's
longest war ever hasn't done what our
leaders said it would
we need our troops but we should use
them sparingly only when we're sure it
benefits our defense and if we go to war
the Constitution says Congress must vote
to declare war I'm glad Senator Paul
argues those points